[Music]
new at noon metro police say two people
were shot and killed at a busy
intersection and right now they are
looking for the shooter
happened around midnight near eastern
and bonanza we have hector mejia there
live at the scene with the latest
details from authorities hector
we are told the victims were struck by
gunfire as they were driving away from
this neighborhood street trying to get
onto eastern and their car
at some point structure here along this
busy avenue
metro police say they learned about this
incident just after 12
30 this morning after neighbors reported
hearing gunshots
officers say they found the male driver
dead on the scene
the passenger was a female she was
rushed to the hospital but despite those
efforts she did not survive
police are now searching for an unknown
man who they say was seen wearing a
hoodie
the pair was in the car on mc williams
avenue near eastern last night when
police say they encountered that suspect
something went wrong and as the victims
drove away that's when
the gunman started shooting we do know
that many nearby businesses have
surveillance cameras and no
word yet from police being able to
review
anything to see if they can better
identify the person
responsible and if you know anything
best to call crime stoppers remember
that you can remain anonymous
near eastern and bonanza hector mejia 8
news
now